nancy pelosi speaker of the house
she was on the wolf build sir i'm sure
you saw that interview she had
which wolf pushed her on a little bit
saying how come you're not calling trump
and she says i don't call trump
i'm not going to call trump i talk to
his people there's no way i'm going to
call trump like she was offended
that wolf asked about calling trump you
were speaker to house before
at a time where you were a disrupter i
mean if people go back and study what
you did you would be categorized as a
disrupter you were able to do something
that hadn't been done
for a long time when it was controlled
by the other side
what was your relationship like with the
president and as a speaker of the house
are you supposed to pick up the phone
and call them and say let's get a deal
done look
you can't compare the two um
bill clinton and i were both sort of
natural graduate students
uh we like sitting around talking about
ideas occasionally he'd call and i'd go
down have a drink with him late at night
and we chat very much like tip o'neill
and ronald reagan
we we negotiated the only balanced
budgets in your lifetime
and we did it by sitting in a room for
35 days
now that's a totally different world now
my advice if trump does get re-elected
is going to be pick the 50 or 60
democrats that are most vulnerable
ignore pelosi totally and build a trump
wing of the democratic party
and just beat her on the floor i think
that's the only practical way to do it
that's the only practical way to do it
against pelosi yeah because she's a
radical
she's not going to agree to anything